usted o alguien que usted quiere puede
haber sido diagnosticado con cáncer de
pulmón este vídeo le ayudará a entender
cómo manejarlo
y los pulmones son un par de órganos
dentro de su pecho que le permiten
respirar
el cáncer de pulmón es una enfermedad en
la cual se forman células cancerosas en
los tejidos pulmonares el tratamiento
para el cáncer de pulmón puede eliminar
o destruir el cáncer
después del tratamiento es muy
importante tener un plan de cuidado con
seguimiento esto incluye ir a las citas
de seguimiento
su médico querrá asegurarse de que el
cáncer no ha vuelto y comprobarse
problemas de salud resultantes del
tratamiento también es importante
realizar tomografías regulares para
controlar el cáncer
si usted está tomando algún medicamento
continúe tomándolo según lo prescrito
por su médico
tomé notas de cualquier efecto
secundario e informe sólo a su médico
si usted ha tenido cirugía de pulmón u
otros tratamientos siga las
instrucciones que le dieron
también puede ser necesario hacer
algunos de los siguientes cambios
saludables a su estilo de vida
si usted fuma es importante que deje de
fumar
esto reduce el riesgo de que el cáncer
regrese o se propague
como una dieta saludable con más frutas
vegetales y granos enteros esto le
ayudará a mantenerse fuerte y sentirse
mejor
limite la cantidad de alcohol que bebe
esto puede reducir el riesgo de cáncer
manténgase físicamente activo
actividades como caminar andar en
bicicleta o nadar pueden ayudarle a
sentirse mejor y menos cansado
hablé con su médico antes de comenzar
una rutina de ejercicios
y saber que tiene cáncer puede ser
abrumador
es posible que tenga preocupaciones
acerca de su afección y cómo afecta a su
familia sus tratamientos y estancias en
el hospital gastos médicos y su trabajo
afortunadamente hay maneras de lidiar
con esto
recuerde que su médico y el equipo de
salud están allí para responder a
cualquier pregunta que tenga
y las siguientes fuentes de apoyo pueden
ayudar a hacer frente a sus
preocupaciones trabajadores sociales
y líderes religiosos
consejeros
y grupos de apoyo
hablé con su médico si tiene alguna
pregunta sobre su plan de tratamiento
medicamentos o cambios de estilo de vida
que lo ayuden a manejar el cáncer de
pulmón